Eat the toilet paper, so it wipes on the way and
Good evening, everyone
My name is Peter and I don't mean to brag but I have a very large brain just like the person who wrote this god-awful
Reddit post
so today we're gonna explore more people with big brains and perhaps
You might find that you are big brain as well. I love this one
You don't have a skeleton inside you you're a brain. You are inside a skeleton
You're piloting a bone mech that is using meat armor. I never felt more
Powerful, I mean technically you're not wrong big brain. Very large brain. I bet this guy can whip out a
Cobblestone generator in half a second my god, so we're all an anime Mecca. That's so cool. To be honest
It's not
Premarital sex if you never get married, baby
What?
I've been lied to a
new scientific study
claims that fertility is hereditary if your parents didn't have any children chances, are you won't either
It took me a second but big brain that's I
Understand this isn't minecraft
It's funny how we we tend to mimic our parents behavior. What you okay? I got one for you guys
Here's one for you big brains. What smells better?
I'm sending 163 subscribers to BünyaminTV subscribers
Nose I
Get it. I
Was like what is a nose smell like oh
You can't spell
v
Nine-year-olds write that down
Things I wish I didn't know. Okay. This is not big brain. Get out of my sight
So I met a cute guy at the bar last night dance with him says he doesn't have a girlfriend
We exchanged snapchat look him up on Facebook, and he doesn't have a girlfriend
He has a wife
the gray
Everyone knows the smartest people in the world Socrates Stephen Hawking's Einstein
They all had very large heads
Einstein's brain weighed only which is less than average adult male Einstein had small brain
small brain
Here's one for you youtube lovers. What's the best way to download a YouTube video?
Screenshot each second and play it on PowerPoint small brain
Hey if the public
Bathroom door is locked
Don't forget to try and repeatedly open it and give the person using it and paralyze be expected
It's like when you're waiting for the elevator and the the button is clearly lit up
But someone comes in anyway and decides to click it for you
The door is locked
I'm sending 163 subscribers to BünyaminTV subscribers
But it I'm having a ship cut in your tennis balls in half allows you to store two more balls in each camp
Thus saving space small brain. Very small. My brain is so tiny. This is another typical
problem with capitalist America, why can't they just they can clearly fit more tennis ball, but they chose not to
Disgusting people will stop showing you pictures of their kids if you whisper are freaky
Under your breath when you look at their focus. Ah
Wow
What a fantastic tip that had that is so helpful
yeah, I
Like that one
Only a fool would buy IKEA furniture
Instead just download the instructions and keep emailing their service department to say that I'm missing a piece
until they ship me all the pieces over a six month period
Swedish break this is an old hack everyone in Sweden
Does this come on don't waste my time being vegan has been so freaking easy
I literally just stare at the Sun and I'm full. Thanks
Photosynthesis. I mean, I never tried it so maybe it works. Ah
If you are behind someone at an ATM late at night
Let them know that you're not a threat by giving them a gentle kiss on their neck
See this is the kind of stuff that I wish
People taught me when I was growing up. It takes 45 muscles to frown but only 10 muscles to smile
Frown all day lose weight get ripped gains
Damn Brian you've been working now. Yeah right now I actually feel it. Damn. I will actually get a big break
My forehead will be massive
The games
Apply garlic to freshly open cut or burn to immediately intensify the pain
Thank you. This is so helpful. Oh
God, I've been barely injured garlic, please. What does that help? Okay. Here you go. Ahh
I keep a fruit sticker on top of my head so that if cannibals ever eat me
He'll have to peel the sticker off first giving me time to escape
How to learn anything ten
Times faster I speed at the video times
1.5 so that I can learn
I'm sending 163 subscribers to BünyaminTV subscribers
Damn oh, I'm sorry. You read books. I listen to audio books at ten times the speed
Oh, I'm sorry. You listen ten times the speed I listened at five RT books at the same time in twenty times the speed
It's quick. It's easy and it's free pouring river water into your socks. Why would I do that? LMI?
It's quick. It's easy. It's free you
Can apply that to anything really buying thirty five words it's quick it's easy. It's
You got the point if you ever feel alone watch a horror movie late at night with the lights up
You won't feel so alone anymore
Thanks, Satan. You're the best when a baby on board sticker is a little faded and beat up
You know the kid is at least a year or two old now and the car is safe to ram. I
Think I remember that one.
I think I keep that one in the memory bank
Thank you very much poke your finger in someone's mouth while they are yawning to establish dominance
Big brain weight might sell was does it to me? I've seen this one. I got a go pregnant in high school
So I told my parents getting bullied and removed
modern from
Require modern solutions
That is awful by the way, just so we adjust so quickly that is not big brain. That is despicable brain. Same thing actually
Firing tip profiling tips knees on your knuckles before a fight in order to inflict poison damage
Damn, hell big brain
Very big very large. Brain. Oh
Oh, here's a good one. If you touch your pee-pee while you watch you can pretend like you were having. Oh
Oh
That took me a long time. Okay?
Hey, oh my god taking a little weight off your check luggage that is actually big brain. I like that
We can't do that in I think European airports. They keep them like dang in
How to get over your fear of the dark as soon as you turn the lights off starts touching peepee poo-poo 'i
Know monster was to see that
While doing it stare at the corner and whisper tenderly, this is for you. I
Always thought about like in a horror movie if someone just does something really crazy to throw the monster off
But I think this one takes surprise. That's extremely large brain. Not even I would think of that. Mr
President Jesus. Well that explains it
If you count their wine snug confuse them by using this move oh my god
life hack pause and say you can show yourself now every time you're about to leave an
Apparently empty room someday, there might actually be someone there and they will be really impressed
I've been doing this for 29 years so far. Nothing happened very large brain
Now if you have the biggest brain of them
All you will be checking out represent calm /pd primer. It is epically big brain
We don't have any big brain merge stuff Spanish cool
Thanks for watching gamers smash like if you enjoy subscribe and remember to just take like life love
Big brain my friend is so big. I don't know how to speak. How do I make outro place what you never played super simulator?
You know, it's fun right I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay. I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free and that's a great price
Swedish prey